you
[Music]
the use of robots in medical care is
really going to open up a whole cast of
diagnostics and therapies that otherwise
we're not accessible what I want to do
is create intelligent tools that will
allow a person with less medical
training perform the kinds of repairs
and diagnostics that surgeons in the
past otherwise had to do my research
group does a lot of work on snake robots
these are highly articulated mechanisms
that can thread through tightly packed
volumes and get to locations that people
and machinery otherwise can't access so
what we want to think about is how can
we apply these robots to surgery one day
I just said to myself I'm going to
figure out how to build a small surgical
snake robot and 20 minutes later the
idea came to me I figured out a way to
manipulate cables so all the motors can
be as big as you want off board and by
marinating these cables we can steer
this snake robot wherever we go it's
rigid in that it can hold its shape but
it's flexible and that it can go in and
around ourian's without disturbing
surrounding tissue areas right now if we
need to have something repaired we
undergo open surgery and that's very
invasive very risky painful costly the
idea is instead of having a large
incision made a couple of small
incisions are made that you can enter in
and drive around your body in a
minimally invasive way without
disturbing the surrounding tissue and
get to the target but you can deliver
your therapy or perform a diagnostic the
implication of this is that you no
longer need to be in a hospital we can
now perform some of these procedures as
office visits we've had three successful
human cases we operated on a person who
otherwise would have required months of
recovery two weeks of hospital stay
instead she went home the next day no
complications
there are many next steps for this
project conceiving new ideas overcoming
technological challenges these are all
frustrating and how to make the robots
smaller that's a frustration that I
sleep with almost every night but it's
because of those frustrations it's
because of those needs we advanced
technology
[Music]